[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig i am so excited
for you to enjoy this episode of not too
deep
as much as i enjoyed recording it we
have
comedian and all sweet magical lady
ardenmarine with us today
you might know her from mad tv you might
know her from her
hit podcast will you accept this rose
covering the bachelor bachelorette
oh we had just the most delightful
conversation i'm still buzzing from it
she's got a brand new book out called
little miss little compton
which is her memoir based on where she
was raised
little compton and we just talked about
everything we talked about
our shared experience being interns on
conan o'brien's show we talked about the
being females in comedy we talked all
about the highs lows ins and outs
of the bachelor bachelor bachelorette
and she gave me some
some information about some former
contestants that blew
my mind and will um probably blow yours
so please please please enjoy this
episode of not too deep with arden
maureen and please i'm like out of
breath because i was laughing so hard
the entire episode please go get her new
book her memoir little
little miss little compton and she's
just so lovely so enjoy this episode not
too deep
hydrating and here i love it hi girl
hi thank you for being here also i've
just learned your last name is
pronounced marine
it is pronounced marine and it does not
look like marine
and it's probably a bastard oh no my my
headphones
it's probably a bastardized version of
the name allegedly
apparently it's like a swedish name but
my brother went to sweden and he's like
that's we don't really know but that's
what is
good to know i want to make sure that
i'm pronouncing it correctly
um i'm so excited that you're here i
have a million questions for you
and your life and your world and
everything that you're up to um
but i want to talk about obviously your
book
which i have right here so exciting
thank you now this is a memoir
yes and why one thing i i'm always
curious about with
writing memoirs what was the reason to
write it
now or when you did you know it's such
an interesting
i tried to sell versions of this
like for like eight or nine years
the first time somebody approached me
and i actually sold
a version of this and then like the
whole like company like
it didn't all work out like but but
um you know it's i actually believe
it's you know of course over the years
you get frustrated and i just assumed it
was never going to happen
and i actually believe the timing i
think this is the right
version and the right draft and this was
it all worked out perfectly because i
remember
another book agent approached me two
summers ago and he was like i want to
take out a proposal with you and at that
point i was so discouraged and kind of
like i didn't want to get my hopes up
again i didn't want to be the girl at
the dance that didn't get asked to dance
you know
yeah that and because it's such a
personal thing that it's not like
if you write it once and it doesn't go
the way you want it you can just write
it again like
this is like a very unique thing and i i
honestly just thought
you know i have a very unique family my
parents married on a dare
they weren't dating they were co-workers
they were trying to get ex
basically you got two weeks vacation
everybody um they'd never
gone on one date they lived in manhattan
they were all everybody was out having
cocktails on new year's eve and they
were trying to figure out
um how to get the maximum vacation time
and somebody figured out that if you
went on a honeymoon you got an extra two
weeks
and so my dad dared my mom to get
married he was like i'll take us down to
south america for i'll pay for a
four-week honeymoon
and then we can come back and we can get
it annulled and
she agreed to the dare they looked for a
bible to swear on they couldn't find a
bible so they swore on a cookbook and
then the next day she called him back
and she upped the ante and she said i'll
i will marry you but i don't want to get
it annulled and then they they were
married till the end they stayed married
for 50 years and then they moved
from manhattan to this tiny tiny town in
rhode island called little compton thus
the title little miss little compton is
i'm from this town of like 3 000 people
called little compton
which is wow tiniest town on earth and
um
so it sort of starts there so whenever i
talked about my family and
and the town when you know doing
monologues at asscat or something like
that people are always very curious i
had a very odd
family in this sort of odd town and
so i thought it would be a good book but
then when this so when this book agent
came
sarah kelowna and guy branham's book
agent was like i want to take out a
proposal i was like
all right like then i thought okay
because it's so much work to put
together a book proposal and i thought
okay
who who am i now like why would i want
to do this now
like mm-hmm and i realized
part of growing up in a house that was
my friend says that
this reads she said it should be called
funning with scissors like it's like a
fun
version of running with scissors like it
was crazy
and that there was so much magic that i
got from it but that was also like i did
not
learn certain life i didn't know how to
do
life and yeah so i wanted to i i was
like okay
i i wanted to write a book for like the
younger version of myself that was sort
of like
here's everything i wish i knew at 21.
like here's everything i wish i knew and
that it's gonna be okay
and you can figure it out even though
you feel like you don't know what you're
doing and
it's okay if you didn't have the perfect
fantasy family and it's okay
if maybe you had some people working
against you like that you can be okay
even if even if it wasn't sort of this
idyllic
upbringing i think that's beautiful
because
like me you grew up without the internet
so
you're in this small town you only have
your parents that are telling you this
is how the world works or this is
this is what we're doing and so you
think that's so normal and everyone else
is doing the same thing so it must have
been
wild to share stories with people
growing up and then hear that like
no that's not what everyone did all the
time i mean truly
how big was the town that you grew up in
i grew up in south jersey
so uh the town that i grew up in was
like one square mile
is very south jersey bleak it's exactly
like
uh you know strip malls everywhere like
exactly what you would
imagine it being yeah um so
a little similar but at least we had the
proximity to like new york city and
philadelphia so there were opportunities
because i knew a lot of my cousins and
stuff on long island like they were
close to new york but they never
went did you guys know how did you grow
i grew up technically like across the
bridge
into new jersey from philadelphia and i
think i went twice in my entire like
adolescent life
but i went to college in northern new
jersey and then moved to new york city
after that
and that was like my big i'm getting out
of this small town
thing did you always want to get out
yeah i had um yeah the the color palette
was always very
dull for me like metaphorically and like
figurative
and literally speaking and so i was like
i just gotta this can't be
it there has to be something else you
know it was interesting just in
you know chatting with people about the
book mike kaplan the comic he has a
podcast tonight and he was pointing out
how
so my parents you know i was aware of
new york because they were from there
but
my mom wanted my brother and i to be
able to entertain ourselves and so
how there was literally no stores there
was no stoplights there was a general
store
the only coffee shop is like in a barn
and an apple orchard and so
and so like my favorite thing like i
wanted to get out of there from the time
i was like
four you know but right but that i would
love to like play store and play and
he's like
you know that her plan actually worked
because
none of that was there you had to
pretend you had to actually
make it up as you went along yeah um
yeah your mom was working with your
imagination very young
yeah and yeah and that she thought she
didn't want us to be over programmed she
didn't want
you know so it was an interesting um
you know i looked like a boy till i was
like 15. it was just an interesting
thing and then to
i moved to new york and i got out of
there i lived in chicago when i was 19
and i just
never went home and right um
it was an interesting thing just to
realize i had no i knew how to be
ambitious but i had
no idea how to have like a relationship
i had no idea
how to do sort of the i knew how to sort
of shoot big career-wise but i had no
clue how to do the rest of
adulthood right i know where the goal is
i don't know any of the steps in between
to get me to that goal
yeah like like what do people do on
sundays like i don't know how what is
anybody like how do
how do you people like how does anybody
set up like a balanced
life and like yeah ruin it how do you
set up like a happy balanced life
well what was it like for you when you
first saw chicago was the first place
that you moved to
outside of little compton yeah i mean i
was in college for a little bit in
colorado
and okay i was just ready to go i i mean
so i was so happy to be there
i started doing improv i had to get a
fake id because it was in a bar
and so in order to perform i had to say
i was 21 and wow
it was amazing because i felt like i
don't know if you experienced this when
you got to new york but it was
sort of the first time i felt like i'd
found my people yeah
it was interesting because it was like
thrilling and one of the most fun years
of my life there but it was also mostly
guys like
there really were not that many women
performing and
and i and i wanted to please them so bad
like i knew i wasn't going to thrive in
that i was so much younger
and i just didn't see that many women
and did you know that at the time
because i had a similar experience like
i moved to new york after i graduated
college i was probably
21 or 22. yeah and it wasn't until
people started asking me like what is it
like being a female in
comedy that i really like put the pieces
together that i guess i like unconscious
consciously like felt but never was able
to
kind of make the light bulb go off for
myself did you know that at the time or
was it more like reflecting
that you realize that well it's
interesting that you say that because i
i also went there you know i'd always
i'd written plays through high school
i'd
like and i'd never heard
the phrase i'd never heard any you know
anything about women being funny or not
like
until i started doing comedy and then
all of a sudden
you know so many women i knew were funny
all my childhood friends in my small
town like
kids are funny you know nobody nobody
told me that i was
odd for a female and then but i remember
when i got to chicago it was the first
time even though it was the most magical
thing
it was also the first time people said
to my face like well women aren't funny
and i eat like and it was in the comedy
world and yeah
what like i've never heard that right
and then you're like is that a joke
i don't know how to take this yeah i
actually found like i don't
keep most of my journals i shred but i
found like an old diary and i could see
myself almost trying to thread the
needle to make some of it okay
oh wow you know what i mean trying to
make these because because i adored
them and i adore being there and i could
see myself trying to like
figure out how this stuff that wouldn't
usually i don't think they could say
today you know back in the day
like it was the first time i felt
somebody really snuffing
like i'd never been aware of my gender
that much yeah
i think at that same that i it was
really put upon me
to think about myself as a female in
this world because that was
to others some form of handicap that i
didn't even realize
was something we discerned in the comedy
world let alone
this was a weakness it's interesting
just hearing you say that like it
it's a yeah it makes me sad for my
younger self
you know like well it's also interesting
there's part of me that's
um like i guess happy that i didn't go
into that world thinking that i had to
wear this like
armor and like prove myself as a female
but also wild that similar experience
that you are forced to try to make sense
of that for yourself without
it being something you discover for
yourself yeah
i it's it and when i think back i
i did know instinctively oh i don't see
like my
path to success here or like i don't see
i don't see how i i knew enough my like
one of the gifts my mom gave me was
always like protect your magic
protect what to protect what is unique
about you protect your magic
guard it that's beautiful yeah and and
like
and there was something where it exposed
me to like the talent and what people
were doing
and and also going okay i'm probably not
going to thrive in
this particular environment and and i
i i need to put i need to get myself out
of here
and then i went to new york and but
how sad because i think if there was
another guy there that was 19
it was a guy there was two of us and
like he thrived there
you know and people treated him like the
wonderkind because he was like the guy
and there was a path to success you know
it was an interesting thing
um you know i mean it is
yeah it is but the cool thing
and to tie into your book and like what
you said earlier
is sharing that memory for younger women
that might not even know they're
experiencing that
right now or i mean now
you know years and years later i think
there is more awareness around
all of that now but even at a time when
you know not long ago that you don't
even realize until you start to unpack
all your [ __ ] that you're like
oh my god this was pretty in my face and
i was just so happy-go-lucky and wanting
to like please and do well and try to
succeed that
i couldn't even see this right in front
of me necessarily
and there was nothing you could do about
it it was like even if you were there
even like even if you saw it there was
no like come over here this
exists you can come play here like like
it was
you know and yet what's i guess i will
say
i'm i i look back on so many
young ladies that did go through and
thrive and just see like
how resilient and like learning to pivot
and find your people
and you know yeah like
just go okay that that that pathway is a
little bit blocked like where
where can i go where where who's who's
my ally what feels safe
like who's who can i make things with
things like yeah
so when you moved to new york did you
feel like you found
a better group a better situation there
i think it was me it was almost between
me and myself you know like there was
something about
um i could feel in chicago
that there was also within me this
desperate
need to please them and like to have
them think i was good and have them
validate it and there was something like
no you have to be the one
you have to like just you're the one
that has to say good job
you know it doesn't have to be somebody
outside of you so i went to new york i
started i got an internship at conan and
then i started doing
stand-up at night and like i was in
elephant macy's santa land i was
waitressing
i was like nannying you know food
delivery everything
and i i also had an internship at conan
yeah okay what was your internship
my internship was just a general
internship it was when i was in college
so i was like taking the train in from
jersey like two or three days a week and
just sitting in that conference room
yeah and just sitting in that conference
room waiting for them to say that like
someone needs to go to whole foods and
get
cone and three apples and make sure
they're not bruised and bring them back
so you're like waiting for jeff ross to
be like go get him some apples yeah
exactly exactly you know i
i remember i was on really early when
all the good interns went to
letterman and so yeah the upshot of it
was if you were
kind of confident you could get some
responsibility
it was truly like the show that it
wasn't cool
and um so i was i was the
i was there five days a week getting
college credit yeah
it was um i was
assisting the script coordinator which
was good because it got me down on the
floor
and yeah in the control room during the
shows
but uh yeah it was interesting to see
the nuts and bolts of like of an actual
to be on the other side of television
production and yeah
which i think helps you as a performer
to sort of have respect for
like how does the show get built and i
had literally actions like
it's the first people i met like i
didn't know anybody in tv and that sort
of
the casting director helped me like i
got another internship for another
casting director which helped me get an
agent like it was just getting accessed
inside like oz yeah no it was
that i remember they had they take your
photo on like a polaroid camera and they
write your name under it and they put it
on this cork board so that everyone
can try to refer to the interns by name
instead of as like
a sheep that are being hurted in this
conference room
and you look through the alumni of all
these interns that have gone on to work
on the office and all of these shows
yeah that was so wild but then you see
how not
glamorous the day in day out of the
actual show making was that it was such
a juxtaposition
every time i was there that i was like
okay
i don't know that i'm processing this
enough in real time but later i'll be
able to look back on this experience
and kind of see how it is because i was
so scared i was so nervous i
was like it was terrifying did you ever
get sent
like sometimes when the copier because i
was so changed the copier
sometimes i would get sent there would
be like elevators that went to like half
floors it felt like being john malkovich
there was like weird internal
so you have this sort of beautiful 30
rock you've got the rainbow room
like the tonight show stage and then in
the bowels of hell
there's like elevators that go to like
half floors
and then you go find some man that's
like still smoking inside
yeah like they have not seen
light there's you're so deep in the
bowels
to find some guy that runs like the
engineering it feels like you're in a
barge
and you're in the bath a hundred percent
as hell
and then you go down for your like two
dollars to borrow meal like um
yeah it was so wild and yeah i was so
scared and so nervous that i was like i
didn't make an impression on
absolutely anyone here because i was
just so worried about doing a bad job
even though there was hardly
anything to do because there were so
many interns and such little
like busy work at the time uh
but it was i was glad for the experience
did you do the page program there
no the page people feel fully like the
tracy flick from election
yeah yes i was not together enough to be
doing
the famous program although i do
remember going
to a page party somehow i got invited to
a page party i'm really bad at pot like
i get so high and i remember getting so
high at a page party like somebody's
flying i think it was jason nash who was
like
i think jason nash was a page like i
went to jason nash's house and got
so high at a page party that i was like
almost paralyzed
party fully like somebody to get me home
because
i was like it was like kryptonite like i
couldn't move i was flying
hooters pantyhose but then there's
nothing sexy it's like thick
nylons and ugh yes
the pages were too uptight i'm glad you
had that same experience because it's
like
something that i buried very deep after
i experienced it because i was like so
embarrassed that i might have done a bad
job
and sometimes i reflect on it and i'm
like oh yeah that happened okay
kind of weird but i have experiences
like that when i look back on them and
when i remember that
like the entire wave over my body is
just shaking yeah i don't know why
i don't know why i don't know why i feel
so ashamed but just like you know
just like just like i want to like dig a
hole in my yard hide it
cover it with leaves and just like for
shame like hide yourself in your shame
hall of fame
and the reality is no one there
remembers me at
all but i'm like i was awful i must have
been terrible
i think the only reason i made any
impression was because i was
literally like week seven like it was it
was
so early on and i i mean it was the
there was like three interns that were
on it and the rest were so
terrible that we were basically like
unpaid like
employees we were just around we were
the only ones they wanted
doing anything so we were just there i
remember got
paid a bag of like i got like 13
a week wow woman who doesn't work there
anymore
but she would like she was not my boss i
loved my boss there was she was a few
steps up she would call the office every
morning she'd be like can you go to the
commissary
egg sandwich so like i made thirteen
dollars a week
she would have me go in the morning and
like buy her stupid [ __ ] breakfast 13
and she wouldn't reimburse me and i
didn't know what to do and i'm like
be mindful like rich lady
just be aware it may not be a lot of
three dollars
14 it may not be much money for you this
is literally
my food this is my comment money for the
week you [ __ ] like
and i and as i don't have i'm too much
of a people pleaser to ask for it back
but like
i just didn't want to pick up the phone
when it rains i knew she'd be asking me
to spend the only money i had on her
stupid
breakfast oh that's so great oh my gosh
okay we have to take a quick break when
we get back um i want to talk
about uh will you accept this rose yes
i have so many questions so we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
hi friends grace helbig here from the
podcast not too deep which you are
currently listening to
hosted by me grace helbig just wanted to
say a couple of things
one thank you so much for listening and
two
if you are enjoying yourself to such a
degree that you'd love to leave
us a um review on the apple store
that would be so appreciated because
again you are very appreciated for
giving us your time your ears your
attention
whatever it may be uh and that was my
couple of things
now back to me me
it's so hard to get started i know
here's anybody listening just keep going
just put one foot in the front of the
other it is so hard to get started it is
keep going and just know that
everybody's been there and just
make some stuff on the side with your
friends but just keep going and just
know
everybody at some point in time had to
start like
it's easier to stay in momentum it keeps
going once you're going
but like just have the faith and just
keep putting right foot left foot it's
okay if you
need to dig a hole in your yard and hide
your table that's fine i still get shame
holes
you know going just keep going it's it's
it's gonna be okay it's gonna be
and the thing the thing that i'm still
trying to accept is that as much as you
think people
are observing you and like judging you
everyone's in their own head
thinking about their own performance
their own world their own lunch their
own everything that as much as you think
that this minor [ __ ] up or thing gets
noticed by everyone it does not
it's hard when you're around a bunch of
strivers though yeah yeah
yeah i feel like that was my entire time
at mad tv like i feel like
oh yeah like well i feel like i'd only
ever been like a comedic actress or it's
like i play molly you play sarah we can
be friends because you play stare and i
play molly we don't like
scripts there was something about mad tv
where it was like
i it was like all the difficulties of
saturday night live with none of the
vanity fair covers
well that's i was asking i wanted to ask
you about that experience because
i don't think anyone e like unless you
actually work or
experience what it's like to be hired on
that kind of show can never really
try to relate to what it's like i think
for me
i think unless you're like the chosen
one
i'm sure even the chosen ones have their
journey you don't even know
mckinnon has a hard right here or there
like i'm sure it was not easy in the
beginning for
like i think for the people that are
sort of
not the picked not the not the cover
girl on vanity
it's hard because you're entering into a
pre-existing machine
and you're com and so there's you know
there's like say there's
10 slots for sketches a week and then
like five of them are going to recurring
characters that have been going on for
many many years
long before you got there and then like
two or three of them are going to like
the celebrity guests
so there's like two or three spots left
and you're reading like 85 sketches
you know and you're and so it it's
really you know and maybe you have a
good week
but then the next week you got to pitch
again and like like
it the emotional roller coaster
seems like you really have to have some
ability to ground yourself
here and there kevin neeland i knew and
he was so sweet he took me out for he
he and his wife took me out for lunch
when i booked it and he was like look
cause he'd been on saturday night live
so long and he was like
look you've it's a marathon this is not
he's like the people that
freak out and can't handle he's like
you're gonna have some weeks where you
don't really have any sketches you can
have some weeks where you
you think your sketch is gonna go great
it's gonna bomb in front of the audience
he's like if you cannot
reset from week to week and just give
yourself a fresh start week to week
and just get like you have always the
good and the bad news is you always have
a fresh chance on monday you know
but like if you get in your head
and you lose your mojo and you get
spooked
like you can't you like it's
almost like an ongoing pilot season that
never
that never ends and the thing is
technically
you have the job already but not really
but you have the job and you're
auditioning for three spots every week
that that either
you're writing or somebody and you're
competing against your friends and like
it um the fun of it the fun of it was
fun
like the writers were so great like so
much so much of the cast was great
like it was it
i'm not somebody that loves competition
i like i i i like to i like improv i
like to play with other people
i like i like to be like collaborators
yeah i like other i like to play with
other people yeah
and some people really thrive like i
wasn't like a sports gal that was like
i'm gonna win you know like i said that
it was not the best environment for me
it sounds um yeah i i auditioned for snl
and it i yeah i like did you do that
thing
did you do that like it was off that was
awesome go to 30 rock and sit in a
dressing room for a question mark number
of hours
and then maybe yeah it was um
wildly taxing on my anxiety and i did
breathe a sigh of relief when i found
out i didn't get it because
in my mind in my mind i was like if
there's any
weird off chance that someone liked me
in this audition which i doubt but if
they do
i am not going to be able to sustain
uh like a mental energy or a mental
stamina to be able to
survive in that kind of environment like
i'm not bred for that
i can't i get too overwhelmed
i knew so i i got the same feeling
i knew i tested i had not at the time
when i tested
i had not done like growlings i had not
done seconds
i didn't have like a stable of
characters so i like just made a tape in
my living room
and then got flown to new york so
they've never been performed in public
like
i've never done these in public i just
dumped them on my tape in my living room
so it's not like i had like
years it wasn't like a well honed like i
know
i know the crowd loves this no me either
i had a terrible taylor swift impression
that made no
sense and didn't sound like her at all
and i can't sing and then
a jersey girl that i did in a video for
the internet one time that was awful and
so it's like yeah if you like this
sure i and i remember like
i at the time i had a very sweet
manager who had a terrible bedside
manner
like with women like a nice big hearted
guy
yeah so i flew to new york there was
four women testing
me amy poehler and two other women
and i by the way i knew it was easier i
am a
i love amy like she should have gotten
it and she did get it like i
remember my manager the more but i was
still like oh my god like okay i'm in
the final four like i've got a 25
chance yeah called me and he goes on the
way to the audition he goes break a leg
kiddo
i mean they already offered it to amy
but who knows maybe
maybe the money's not going to work out
i'm like why did you talk
why before i before i auditioned like
can you they hate to fly me here they
put me up at their weird hotel like
can't you just like like why did you
tell me that right as i'm going
up in the elevator at 30 rock like and
then that's awful
and then i remember auditioning but i
didn't hear for like a month i guess
because her contract was speaking
and like these reflections yes and i
remember
like praying that i didn't
get it yeah and i actually booked mad tv
that year
and i said no because i
i because i knew i couldn't
handle it like it was sort of so and
then and then i actually took
four years and i went through io and i
went through
like i got my my insides i did like
yeah and i did a lot of like live
performing and
because i knew for myself both my own
insecurity and my lack of like my 10 000
hours performing in public with that i
thought okay i booked it once
let me actually go get the skills like
yeah
like i'm sure i'm sure a guy would be
like great i'm just let me start
swimming but i knew for myself
if i was gonna stand any kind of a
chance of succeeding there
i knew i needed to go do the work and
and um so i did i went through the whole
like i got myself ready i did my own
show like
and then i and then i did it four years
later that's
really great because that's you know
crazy well it's having like the patience
with yourself
to know that like your mom said you have
a magic
or magic that you want to preserve but
let me go get some professional training
and then really express my magic in a
way that i feel
good and grounded about so that i can
protect it more in this environment than
i could before
you that's really true i think
you know and the goal wasn't i didn't i
actually never thought i would
do it you know because like that the
goal i think was i knew i wanted to make
things i knew i liked writing things i
thought maybe i tried to write my own
show or whatever but like
when it came around again and i
re-auditioned and i had
you know i remember talking to my mom
and we made like a list the pros and
and and i had done a bunch of pilots
that didn't get picked up
and i knew katie siegel from uh sons of
anarchy and like oh yeah i mean i just
knew her a little bit i ran into her
like
she was having like a like a ice cream
on the street and i was debating about
i realized i was very scared of a sketch
show more than
it wasn't that i thought i was better
than i i was just scared that i
i didn't know that i could thrive there
and i was like you know
and at the time it's so much different
now but at the time like if you did
sketch
for a little while you weren't really
like a real actor you know
so um but i remember her saying like
arden it's easier to stay on tv than to
get on tv you just need to get on tv
just go get on tv and it was such a
like i've always be grateful to mad tv i
think of it almost like um
it made me like officially a comedian i
started doing stand-up again like
it i think i think it was almost like
going to grad school
it was the hardest job i think of it as
like four years of grad school
yeah and you like got a a real
opportunity to prove yourself
in a way and i'd audition with all these
sort of like weirdo
awkward characters and that they didn't
want that like they
i was a redhead when i did it they
bought me they dyed my hair blonde and
like
they wanted me as like the blonde girl
in the party dress and which bum me out
but then i
actually found it kind of like okay like
can i be funny and not be like weird
looking do i have to
like not be the old lady or like not
make myself like you know
can i like can i worry just like if this
is what they want and this is the only
airtime i'm gonna get if they're gonna
put me
can i still be funny and not you know
and that was actually
good for me it was uncomfortable because
it's not how i thought of myself but it
was a good
it was sort of a gift to force yourself
to go okay
i guess i could do that yeah explore a
side that you wouldn't have
on your own necessarily i also wonder
to talk to kind of like lead into your
podcast will you accept this rose which
is about
bachelor bachelorette i wonder if your
experiences when you said like
each week was a new opportunity to start
fresh
if that gives you uh more genuine
compassion for the people that go on to
something like the bachelor bachelorette
i have so much compassion for
i have a anybody of empathy just for the
human condition truly
i mean when i say i looked like barb
from stranger things until i was 15
being like that i have i have compassion
for mankind
truly i have so much compassion i really
truly believe most people are doing the
best that they can
so that's why also when people come on
my podcast will you accept this rose um
i have i i very much i'm like we don't
hate watch it but we make a lot of jokes
about it but these are real
people right you know it's interesting i
think
instagram has really sort of changed the
game there because
i think a lot of people now come on just
to quit their jobs and become
influencers
yeah there's we've had some guests from
the the series here
and they're all doing books and doing
their own different
lines or podcasts or clothings or all
kinds of things
which is very cool um but they're in
what what season is this for them 109
yeah yeah and so it does
feel like for them it must be difficult
to find a genuine
real person that's looking for love
i mean that's why i actually would argue
that this
this so this uh do you watch the show i
do watch the show i haven't watched this
season we just had kendall long on an
episode
uh not long ago yeah we talked a little
bit about
this season i watched the first episode
but i don't know what's going on i know
that it was claire now it's tasha
that's that that happens tonight that
happens tonight tonight
here's my pitch of why here's my pitch
of why claire
while while a little bit batshit is a
terrific bachelorette
because i think because she's 39
and i think she's had a bunch of
tragedies in her life
and i truly believe that this human
being could not
give two shits about a people magazine
cover
she does not want to come sell fabfitfun
she's
not looking to sell tanner she wants a
husband
yesterday and i think she has like a
real cinderella fantasy of like
this prince charming but she is sort of
all alone in the world and i
so i think she's like the combo of like
the disney princess fantasy
combined with legitimately she is all
alone in the world and
and she's old enough that she's like i
want this
yesterday and that's right yeah fun
bachelorette and it's a perfect amount
four episodes and it's the perfect
amount in and out and then we get the
beauty of tasha
and and she already had a
an engagement through the show right i
remember seeing
whatever their olympic or like winter
games
or winter games yeah i saw that and then
yeah that they had their reconnection
after the show was done or something
on the reunion ironically if you watched
the first episode you noticed they
didn't mention that
in her like this season yeah completely
edited out that the last we saw of her
she had just accepted a ring it was like
going off into the sunset with french
canadian benoit
that's what i thought that's why i
couldn't believe that she was the
bachelorette again and i was like well
this is gonna have to be a real
heavy-handed storyline of why the other
thing didn't work out
but i guess not that's the beauty of the
bachelor world you just if it doesn't if
you don't mention it it doesn't exist
and that's
fine i'm curious what your thoughts are
on that whole franchise about
how where can they go from here how do
they elevate it because i think
my i got into it late i started watching
a few seasons ago
who was your first who was your first
season i think my first season was
rachel
but it was great bachelorette yeah but
it was like halfway through her season
with a bunch of girlfriends that were
diehard fans and so i really had no idea
what was going on but i knew it was
important because there was a lot of
energy in the room about it
yeah then i got really into it for a
couple seasons and then ari's season
kind of like
yeah he was gross yeah and so i fell off
from it and then i tried to watch
claire this season but it just felt very
repetitive to me a little
flat i guess but maybe start tonight
because i think okay tasha is smart
taste is a fox tasha is fun
and doesn't search for fools gladly yeah
yes i thought who was she with from
paradise
didn't she reconnect with john paul
jones yeah yeah yeah
jpj yeah yes i also started late i
started
i truly i didn't watch the bachelor i
love i love a competition reality i love
like a top chef a project runway
i used to watch top model i love drag
race i love a
great british bake up i love having to
make something in an evening
yes i wasn't until i've now i was not a
housewives a bachelorette that wasn't my
thing
i'm just pulled garbage but um but so i
started watching it like
four years when caitlin's season
somebody told me to watch it and i was
like
i have a life i'm not gonna watch it
when i watched it i was like oh my god
this is amazing
and then i had a fever dream that i
needed to start a podcast and talk about
it with funny people
and that's great i almost treat it like
it's like a sporting event i don't read
any spoilers we do draft picks who's
drunk on the first night
who's like gonna be the villain so this
is a few years ago
we'll do it we do it from their bios
what season is this
this is so we have drunk on the first
night we picked the crazy ones we picked
number one basically like who's gonna
get boned in a hot tub in acapulco but
like
and then i like that somebody wrote like
this is a woman that my friend says has
a face on her face like
he's got a new face like some people
look like they were probably like
a natural beauty once but then they had
so much saying so many things done that
they put a face
yeah that's a different face on another
face
that's a face on the face so that's so i
just treat it almost like it's like my
it's like my i watch football or it's my
yeah
it's like a gaming season of who's gonna
go all the way so i'm curious
it's gonna be like a reboot tonight yeah
are there new guys
is it just are they bringing back the
guys that claire cut do they have
different guys
quarantining for tasha i think the guys
are gonna be pretty excited like there
was a shot
of her coming out of the pool last week
where she it was the equivalent of like
daniel craig and um
she was like literally coming out like
her bazooms were just
spectacular out of a pool and like a red
bikini just booming
just yeah we are awake
and paying attention we are awake
because claire while being a very foxy
later he's been so insane and just
locked and loaded on this one guy
this party city model she
i don't go deep diving on anything but
people send me things but if you
google google dale taco party city
oh no so basically it i think it says he
just
he's like a former like a football
player i think
but he's a party city model
so he doesn't oh my god
i just tried to google it and asked me
if i meant del taco party city
yeah he does after here's him here's one
that's um hold on
it's he's dressed as a gladiator and
superman and a taco
he does like all their outfits which by
the way he's a really fun job i love
party city i know
i love a party favor you think i'd be
mad to do the party city model
i think again i know these are people
that have jobs like i
i've always wondered what these people
how do they where do they exist in the
real world
and he's a party city model wow that's
somebody's gotta be the party somebody's
gonna model that taco the taco's not
gonna model itself grace
it's very true it's very true now i have
a question
how has because like you said this is
a a show that from the outside seems
very trite or trivial or
you know superficial whatever but the
bachelor nation
is a very devout almost religious sort
of community
yes yes are you accepted in that
community
are you an enemy of that community fully
accepted
i'm deep in i'm friends with a
contestant i'm a super
fan because i'm also i'm not a snarky
super fan like
right i love it i love it
i i am like oh they come to my holiday
parties
i am so deep in yeah so i'm fully
accepted
amazing they know i could i don't want
to know spoilers i don't want to know
like i'll hear the gossip afterwards but
i don't
you're a purist oh my god
it is awkward when you've made jokes
about people and then they're in your
podcast
you're like hey hey nice to see you
you remember carly and evan uh did you
see that bachelor in paradise you would
remember he was the dick doctor
and [ __ ] babies okay
he was the only one that seemed like a
little off but he'd probably listen to a
podcast
gotcha yes yes wow okay that's so
wonderful okay we have to take one last
break let me get back i have a couple
internet questions for you so we'll be
right back with more not too deep
all right and before we get into these
internet questions i'm going to ask you
the two questions ask every single guest
that is on the podcast
the first is who alive or dead would you
most like to throw cold spaghetti
at thank you for asking i thought about
this
i thought in advance okay because it's
cold spaghetti
that feels personal like as much as i
would love to say like
some awful historical figure right if
i'm very
honest it's a former co-worker of mine
that
was my friend who i realized was working
against me the whole time
and that was the most hurtful like i
felt so betrayed
i think that so i feel like cold
spaghetti is like a
personal friend like like that that
that's the specific thing it's not gonna
hurt anybody
it'll probably actually wash off like
it's probably not even gonna permanently
ruin your shirt
so like but the satisfaction of throwing
cold spaghetti
i think that's somebody that's really
hurt your feelings yeah i thought it out
i like that because it does feel like
you're throwing a bit of shame
on them and it's like you have my
feelings
you know who is your answer is yours a
personal hurt
oh mine's like everyday someone
different
because i also think that it's um
it can be a celebratory thing i think it
can be like a fun
thing and they're like a gatorade like
we won the game spaghetti
yeah and so there's part of me that like
really would love to see
pete buddha judge have like a cold
spaghetti moment
but in like a in like a sassy loving way
that's fun for him i like that for him
yeah great okay the other question i ask
every single guest
is to tell us your worst pant [ __ ]
story or a close
call but you can only use three words or
three small phrases
so mine is college jogging front lawn
okay that is very similar to yours mine
is coffee
jogging neighbor's lawn
oh yeah yeah that's a tough one
neighbor's lawn twice
two neighbors really
uh marking your territory twice
i was like you know what i've already
done it on this line the second one was
like you know what
[ __ ] them let's go this long let's
spread the wealth a little bit here
exactly exactly okay uh let's get into
some of these internet questions for you
um this is a little bit opposite of what
you just told us via the spaghetti
question but
who is the nicest comedian that you have
ever worked with
oh i love that
i love he's a rascal but his
heart is huge i love
bobby lee i love bobby lee
he can't keep a secret
he is a little messy he is a complete
imp like he is he is like he is
truly like a little sprite that is like
but he means no evil like his heart is
pure and he's such he's just such a
little rascal
but he but his heart is huge so i would
say
bobby lee i also love
lauren lopkis oh yeah well okay here's a
question about that
someone asked arden i love your
friendship with lauren lapkus how did
you two meet
we love each other we text all day every
day pandemic like who fades away like
right you're my favorite people it's
like well i'll see you in 2023
i guess you don't know who we like for
whatever reason
i love lauren so much how did we meet
she did my podcast a few times
i don't even know but then we started
having a monthly
dinner date with brian sofie we would do
we would have a dinner and like
we would rotate we would go to a new
restaurant each time and
one person would pay for it and then
we'd rotate and that person would just
get to
um just we would rotate who paid in the
restaurant and then
because i really just liked both of them
and i felt like it was like there were
two people that i actually like
courted as friends yeah like that i
thought i was like i would be their
friend
and then and then lauren came to my
hometown she came to the little compton
sort of brian
and then laura and i went to new york
and then it's just again you never know
in life like
sometimes you'll have a friend lunch
with somebody and it doesn't go anywhere
sure and also like making friends as an
adult
is sometimes awkward and weird dude
when you moved i found l.a even more new
york
new america hit my stride pretty quickly
yeah elaine
it took me a while to find my girlfriend
mm-hmm
and then some awkward friendship like
would you like to have a
meal like like like courting recording
your
female friends yeah and then when you're
not in the confines of like your work
structure like
so say you meet on a job and then that
job ends
do you have anything to talk about like
you don't know if you can transition
without like oh brian and uh
you know wardrobe like you know like
right and then you're like do you still
want to talk to me after this linking
thing that we have in common is gone
like how do we most people no they don't
they don't want to talk to you
most people is like most people are camp
friends do you think yeah
we're gonna have this you know we're
never gonna remember like it's always
gonna be
camp camp whatever forever and it's like
not really you can't transition to your
winter school friends
i feel like you're lucky i feel like
you're lucky if you
truly make one real new friend a year i
try to make
one friend a year oh that's a good thing
to think about
it's hard it's very hard and like you
said in pandemic
you really find out like who does wanna
keep talking to you
and like who is totally okay with
not knowing your life for eight months
and it's tiring
everybody's exhausted let's be real he's
like
this is a lot like this this year is
a garbage fire it's literally all like
everybody just said their turtle shell
just yes and so and there's like you
said compassion and forgiveness of
everyone's
handling things in their own way
pandemic pass you get a pandemic
yes a hundred percent you also don't
know in life who you're gonna keep as a
friend like you just don't
i wouldn't have guessed my friend who
wrote my forward debbie ryan the star of
insatiable
we did insatiable together little did i
know that this
former disney star would be one of my
best friends she came to a little
compton too she came with me and brian
and lauren like
i talked to her all the time during the
pandemic you just you
never know who your pal is going to be
true i would never have guessed that of
everybody on that shawl
that that young lady would be like
that's my friend that's time
ryder day no rain shall fall on debbie
ryan
yeah you can't deny a kindred spirit
though we have we are definitely spirit
animals she
she's also a rascal she's a rascal oh
that's so sweet
uh okay someone to know what's your
favorite bachelor or bachelorette moment
that might be a difficult question
oh gosh i mean my favorite bachelorette
period my favorite bachelorette was
caitlyn i thought that she was
she had a sense of humor she was fun she
was a full rascal
um the first thing that came to mind
although i got sick of chad by the
end because he actually felt like a
dangerous
psychopath but i did enjoy
when he had the double date the two on
one
with alex the marine and they're in
those that awful woods whistling in the
woods
when he just turned to him and he was
like you don't like milk man
you should like milk milk's delicious
and he goes well life ain't all
blueberries and paper planes and i
thought
you're true psychopath and guess what
that gentleman now
if you look up chad johnson uh-huh he
literally is doing
what is that porn site like that popular
like
and they'll be like foreign chris
harrison guess what i just [ __ ] in
front of your house like
he's like parks his hummer and films
himself
[ __ ] in front of his enemy's house
incredible
that's incredible that's such a great
that he actually thought about
got the hummer actually it's funny he is
actually executing it
and he'll be like i'm [ __ ] just like
your new he did it in front of jojo and
jordan rogers house he's like
your new home has been tainted every
time you walk through the door
think of me [ __ ] on your doorstep
wow out of your gym you're crazy
that's like next level villain status
right i mean i'm not i don't want to
encourage him i don't want him to come
do it in front of my house
but i but i respect if he could just
take it from an 11
to like a seven and a half yeah i think
he's actually legitimately dangerous
like i think he's
i think he's i don't i don't go too deep
diving on him i actually think yeah
bad thing so let me just also say i'm
not supporting this man in the least
right plus would like to say i enjoyed
the blueberry and people playing and i i
think it is insane that any human yeah
his equivalent of throwing cold
spaghetti is parking like an american
flagship bummer
and doing it to taint your household
there is
so much to unpack in that that is
so wild when people actually
execute it it's like beyond coming up
with it that they didn't
stop themselves that they paid the money
to do it oh my god yeah it there's so
many um decisions that had to be
thought of and said yes to and done to
get to that point
well there was never a point where it's
the equivalent of like road trip we're
going to
vegas there's never a point where like
all right i'm tired
maybe i should stop like we didn't get
to vegas yet maybe i should go back to
bakersfield like there's no point where
it it's such a long distance journey
that there's so many points
along the way where you could easily
give up on your dream of executing this
yeah there's like something dangerous
about his ability to focus his rage in
such a specific way
yeah is a little uh a little
i feel badly giving a psychopath this
much air time
i wish he didn't have like it's
his criminal mind is yeah it's on
another level i've never seen anything
like it i don't
i don't need another one like i don't
like an actual scary person on my show
but i
did it but i did enjoy that moment i'll
stick to the party city
model level taco taco dale are you
kidding me
it's like make him perfect and he can't
be so perfect that
he you know that he's at least a party
to their tacos
i love it okay arden i could talk to you
for 17 hours but here's the last
question for you that i'm sure you've
answered
um probably many times but if you could
plan a full date on the bachelor
bachelorette
what would you be what would you plan
how would it go nobody's asked me that
i always ask no people always ask me
i asked people what they would wear
getting out of the limo yeah yeah
i met i would i always panic i know i
would panic i would
i would do like i would be bad i would
do like a mullet dress because i'd want
to show my legs in the front but then
i'm like i still wanted to be formal
so i'd probably do like a hot pink i
wanted to pop something like a hot pink
mullet dress it would not
it would be misguided it wouldn't be
sexy
i thought you were saying misguided the
clothing company i misguided
hashtag fabfitfun backslash misguided
what would you wear out of the limo i
would go straight
sweatpants and like t-shirt and just be
like this is the reality of what i'm
about
that's what lauren lopka said yeah oh
really yeah this is
i wouldn't want to i would really try my
best to not wear a dress the entire time
i was there
lower the lower manage the expectations
yeah okay
my dream date first of all i want to be
in like a castle in ireland or something
i want to be somewhere exotic so i want
to oversee so i've made it to like
i've made it to thailand i've made it
i'm i'm on i'm like in the final four or
five
okay okay we're not at fantasy suites
yet because i'm not ready to go get
i don't want to go get herpes from
somebody but we could like dry hump okay
so like
the equivalent of like i want you i want
to be past the no name band i want to be
past that brand where they're like i was
so happy when to neil art showed up like
i wanted to be like
i remember back in the day they had the
cranberries plate i want them to dust
off
somebody cool yeah give me somebody cool
from like
like you two played you know what i mean
somebody from like my
that would throw me from like like the
dave matthews band like yeah yeah yeah
but like i remember like losing my
virginity to this like okay great so
there's dave matthews
okay and then i guess i would go cold
weather because i don't want to have to
wear a bikini
yeah i would go like i've got like a
coco or like i'm walking around the city
like some cute
northern city so i can be bundled in
we like sample some like scotch or
something
and then i need fireworks i need like a
ride i need i need at the very end
there's dave matthews
and then i want to get like dry humped
against a wall in an alleyway with like
cobblestones underneath me like
i want to be so grinded against a wall
that i like that i actually want to go
get herpes like
four hours against the wall by some like
party city model
and i'm so hot for the real thing
because there was
matthews and there was a costume and
that taco was just getting at it
and like but i got to wear like a hood
and like
i had like a muff on and like that's
what i would do because i didn't have to
wear like a tankini and like stuck it in
and be like sorry i have big boobs but
they're heavy and low
like you know what i mean that's what's
going on
here like a nook of the north gets dry
humped in an alley
yeah and you know when you're wearing
that many layers you really have to work
for that dry hump
yeah it's like definitely like a jean
situation like a college or a high
school
denim jean it's like yeah kind of hurts
it's like
hurting your pubic bone because he's
clearly in a taco custard
for warmth so like it's definitely
hurting but you're like
but he's dead but he's in some kind of
like cowl neck sweater that's terrible
some stylist has put him in and you're
in like a high-heeled booty that you
can run around doubling in even though
you're in a high-heeled booty
and there's just slow dissolves what's
your dream game
wow oh man it's gonna be hard to beat
that one
i know that's so good i feel like my
mind goes to like medieval times
or something like that which i feel like
they've done stuff like that
on that show really yeah oh yeah see i
would want to go to like
something like a dave matthews but like
performance wise
so there's like something else to take
the attention and the sound away from
all of the grinding that goes on
you don't want to have to like slow
dance in front of a crowd of women that
are filming on their iphone
you're standing on a raised platform
slow dancing alone in front of a crowd
of like
housewives that are filming you i don't
even like slow dancing
with my boyfriend at like weddings so
like the slow dance on television
is like the worst punishment someone
could have
like a height difference not a tall gal
i'm not a child
you're a tall gal i remember yeah at
midnight i'm like that's a beautiful
tall gap
i'm a break of water oh thank you i'm a
tall lady so i
uh i wouldn't want to wear heels or do
any of that kind of stuff
yeah slow dance that's a better slow
dance than like
yeah but see i would just hate i i would
opt out of the slow dancing
situation too i'd probably be like do
you want to get high and watch alone
on the history channel it's a really
cool survivalist competition show
but i would only do that if you were
dressed as an nbc page i love it
what is alone oh alone is another
competition show but it's about
survivalists that like
live outside and they try to outlast
each other in the wilderness by
themselves
yeah it's a little different because
they are alone but
it's uh and clothed but they're so good
at building shelters and surviving and
something about uh watching it knowing i
don't want
to ever do anything like that is very
pleasant it's like kind of a nice show
to have on in the background
there's a lot of hunting and a lot of
like showing animals and all that kind
of stuff that i'm not into
what channel is this on the history
channel my boyfriend i just got into it
it's a good bingeable show in
if you got time i love me i love me on
deadliest catch i like an outdoor show
i will say this have you ever watched
naked and afraid i've watched some
yeah did you ever watch the first season
there was a i believe he was a former
marine he was a ginger and i say this as
a real life ginger he was a redheaded
gentleman
he was down near the like equator so he
was like some island
close to the equator he got he was so
sexist
and then he immediately got so sunburned
that all of his skin and shoulders it
was like peeling off
and then he drank the water and then he
was such a dick but then he did a
like a circle of diarrhea around the hot
in the bed that they do
no i never watched the first season oh
my god your
favorite is like kind of click through
and look for the ginger guy
the gender that got sunburned and like
made a trail of diarrhea around
their sleeping quarters oh my god
do yourself a favor grace you need that
you need to make money
passphrase i'm making a note thank you
for that
arden this has been so fun thank you so
much for this conversation
my only regret is i didn't i didn't
purchase and wear an nbc page outfit
next time um where's my cosplay that's
my cosplay
look yeah oh before we wrap up i almost
forgot
um every guest that is on the show gets
a personalized fortune cookie from
us to you so i believe melissa has
emailed you a digital fortune cookie
melissa is on it yes honey yes honey
yes melissa excuse you excuse you for
nailing it so hard there she is
we clicked on a digital tarot card for
you and it was the wheel of fortune
and it just said no please decipher that
how you will
well that feels terrible you guys don't
put a curse on me
well maybe it's uh maybe it's a good
sign that you don't need fortune you
have so much goodness in your life
already
maybe it was like don't go work with pat
sage
yeah that's true no no no no no
no pat stage uh
arden where can people get the book
where can they
see everything that you're up to if they
don't know you guys got the book
just get the book it's so fun it's a
fast read there's pictures
in it if you want a signed copy of the
book and if there might be a few left
with a free custom little miss little
compton tote bag which is
cute you can go to arden marine book
don't kid yourself that looks like arta
myron book it's
y r a-r-d-e-n-m-y-r n book dot com
i also host will you accept this rose on
i heart radio or wherever you get your
podcast i'm on instagram twitter and
facebook as
arta marine m-y-r-i and great awesome
this was so fun
like i said come back talk to us we
could talk for hours and hours and hours
deep dive into all of it the feeling is
mutual and if you do
watch tasha yeah oh i will
let me know if you want to come play
with us because it's the most fun thing
you'll ever do
oh i can't wait i will for sure let you
know because i have run out of so much
alone to watch so i need to move on
um thank you again arden so much guys go
get the book go follow everything she's
up to she's just
incredibly lovely and hilarious and you
won't regret seeing
everything that she's doing and we'll
see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep deep not too
deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music